olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dark sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo hoje trago-vos aqui várias
animações de five nights at freddy's o
quê que vocês apoiaram bastante aquele
vídeo da animação de five nights at
freddy's e vocês pediram mais por isso
eu resolvi voltar a fazer isso mas desta
vez em vez de vermos uma animação vamos
ver quatro meu deus as coisas estão
evoluir mundo é maravilhoso mas vamos
que vamos as animações quero só dizer
uma coisa que eu descobri hoje de manhã
vocês sabiam que eu nasci no dia do meu
aniversário só a primeira animação chama
de springtrap forbidden love 1321 ok
temos aqui o springtrap mexer em
máquinas de vídeo games aquelas aquelas
lojas antigas e só não existe osasco vou
até comprar jogar alguém apareceu atrás
hotel e o foco em outra máquina ele tem
um jogo ali
a festa foi com uma animação interior
ele vai matar pessoas
eu não posso
e aí o que é isto aí não pode aí ela
apaixonou-se e eu sei pessoalmente
personagens estão de portas ok obrigado
por me lembrar em porque eu não animação
passada eu não calculei que fossem lá os
outros e o que importa meu deus ai meu
deus a tua questão é tão quatro eu perdi
não é um demônio não me paixões por
homens e demônios springtrap não é preso
em
e não isso não pode acontecer para além
de serem dois homens aqui está tudo
bugado e tem que ter um demônio no corpo
springtrap não faz isso banho também é
demônio né eu acho que ficava em um para
o outro final
e vamos lá passar a próxima esta
chama-se para o keylight guarda ou seja
o guarda-noturno assustador 32.com
estamos fazer o pônei e aqui fica ali ao
lado ou temos quer já
o fred também tá ali isso parece ser
aquela ambiente e do five nights at
freddy's 1 a primeira vista acho que é
isso
é ali onde supostamente nós estamos
whatafuki vamos jogar tony é que eu
parecia ser o slender não é eu acho que
eram slender é um gato é o se lembra de
como a escolha do questionário que era
que tomar e não era acho que era uma
coisa assim parecida mas existe um junto
com um gato com aquela cara ó não temos
que eles estar o slender boni se
instalar resultar eu acho que se lembrem
bem mais forte que eles todos juntos
o rock in rio do peixe ok eu sofri
animação e sim o se lembra é mais forte
do que qualquer outro bicho a face da
terra - amar aquela porta tem aquele
vestido eu nunca conseguiu entender o
porquê daquilo que eu cabelo e eu não
sei não precisa ela pega o pulso meu
ninguém mais forte o carro samara depois
sim até a próxima animação é o boxe
lobos boni vocês são por este título bem
e vai pegar aqui alguma coisa 321 bora
lá ok já deu o romance ainda agora
começou a animação eles estão comer
relembrando com foco ser homem e bonito
também
a camille vai dar molho
e aí as consequências dos ok vamos assim
é pior mas não um pouco citado ficar
contigo só que ficar cara no reborn não
faz isso que é pior mesmo ai ai
e é uma gosta de robôs foi que ele disse
[Música]
e aí
e eu acho que não vou comentar nada
acerca desta animação porque isso por
muito estranho muito próxima animação da
é um pouco maior chama-se over power que
diz que vai empurra o verde ruas power
bora lá 3 2 1 1/2 pessoal vamos ficar
porque com este vídeo e estas foram as
quatro animações que eu escolhi para nós
irmos hoje porque assim eu vou continuar
com esse tipo de vídeo se vocês quiserem
né mas eu acho que vocês querem é isso
pessoal como que o like e favorito fica
bem e até a próxima tchau
e aí